What hasn't happened in?
It is certainly my life term or my recollection is a guy like Brennan and
clapper, deciding that a politician or someone running this one,
president Trump in this case,
Kennedy Trump in this case was not good enough to assume the presidency.
So they were doing things to kneecap his administration.
So.
Comes in basically as the firecracker to, you know,
throw the chess board up the whole thing, um,
the administrative state or the deep state,
or maybe you have a different phrase for it.
This is this idea of a constant group of people
that stay no matter what administration comes and goes.
Can you just explain a little bit about what that actually is?
Lord have mercy. All right. So folks, uh, who get there,
uh, those jobs, you are there for 20, 25, 30 years. Um,
and it's true that you out last, all ministrations.
Are these jobs. Like let's really do like the most base level here,
because this is the type of thing you hear, deep state and everyone online.
You're, you're either a conspiracy theorist or an Alex Jones guy,
or you give me something like, what are these people actually do?
All right. So when you let's shake the CIA, right?
So someone like me who went in as an operations officer,
so somebody basically goes out in the field or Coots buys and steal secrets,
right? You have a tremendous amount of power, right?
A tremendous number of tools to read people's emails,
listen to people's phone calls. I mean, you can call it surveillance teams.
You have a lot of power to do or accomplish the mission. And through that,
some people had this mistaken belief that they are now anointed to make
decisions, uh, writ large in terms of foreign policy. That is,
they are the ones that have the knowledge to decide what the nation should or
shouldn't do on a particular issue instead of simply informing a policy maker to
say, here's what I know to be true. Here's what I think we ought to do.
But here are slew different options and you make the choice for the call because
you're a representative, the people, and I am simply a tool.
So basically they sort of have access to all of this information.
And then after years of it,
you start thinking you're bigger than the people that are coming. Yeah.
So one of the most infamous spies Aldrich, Ames who worked for the CIA,
but indeed worked for the Russian secretly was eventually found out,
led to over 100 individuals, assets being killed when he was asked,
why he did it. He said, I know what's best for the nation's foreign policy.
And I'm going to act on that. So that degree of hubris, right?
You go in loving your country, embracing the flag. You're there,
the CIA for the right reasons.
But now suddenly you've come to this belief that you are anointed,
that you are somehow that the guardian of the Republic beyond
the, the, the, the defensive nature that, that you,
the people your government has, has anointed on you to actually do good things,
to support the constitution and support policy makers. Now,
you think that you're actually a King or a queen behind the scenes,
and you will move the, the, the will levers of power.
And you will decide who gets briefed on what pieces of information or you don't
brief certain pieces of information. I'll give you an example. So I worked a,
an issue that I, I can't talk a ton about,
but an Asia related concern and what we were briefing the white house was that
what we, as the CIA were doing in terms of record covert action operations were
incredibly successful, but I actually knew that that wasn't true.
So I sat down with the analyst and I said, it helped me understand why, uh,
you all make this judgment, like, well,
we don't make that judgment that we don't believe that's true.
So I collated all this information. I presented it to our,
what we call the seventh floor. And I said, you know,
serves what we are presenting to the white house, uh, as effective isn't.
And they said, well, you know, the song of dancing. And then they said, look,
why don't you read that downtown? Right.
Knowing that I had absolutely no ability to do that. Right.
So they just sort of,
it took an issue that they knew would be problematic for the agency for
themselves. Uh, they lied about it to the NSC and to the white house.
And they decided what was best for America's foreign policy,
as it relates to that particular country in that particular issue around weapons
of mass destruction. So it's a,
one is a tiny little example of how the deep state can decide
what a nation should or shouldn't do.
Th th th th the rubric that I think has been crossed that's that kind of stuff
is more typical Washington.
What hasn't happened in it is certainly my life term,
or my recollection is a guy like Brennan and clapper,
deciding that a politician or someone running this one,
president Trump in this case, Kennedy,
Trump in this case was not good enough to assume the presidency.
So they were doing things to kneecap his administration
before, or I should say his election, his ability to become an elected official.
Yeah. Can you, can you explain a little bit about what these guys were.
Doing? So let's just start with the dossier. Yeah.
Because to me, you've had tweets deleted over this. I mean,
Twitter tried to try to bite you and ban you because you started as a former
CIA guy, you started talking about what, what Brandon was up to, what they,
what these guys were doing. And they, they were going to boot you off Twitter.
And then eventually there was enough of an outcry.
I tried to help as much as I could to get you back on there. Yeah.
Yeah. So, all right. If we just look at the dossier,
we knew for a considerable amount of time that this information was unvetted and
uncorroborated, it was, it was internet. Rumor, I think,
is what was in the IEG report, right? So it was one know that this was garbage,
but yet it was utilized by the FBI to continue surveillance of a Trump
campaign officials.
This is before the election, this dossier,
which is basically an internet rumor is now used.
So the CIA can use spying techniques. But let me,
let me just tell you how I'm just trying to get me down. Yeah.
We had a foreign spy.
It was hired by a domestic political opponent inject this garbage
into the system, which if you work in the field,
do you know that any Russian sources are oftentimes controlled by Vladimir the
SVR? Right? So unless you really,
[inaudible] amazing these Russians.
So we're pumping this fake garbage that we haven't vetted into the political
system or using it for surveillance purposes. And now,
and here's the kicker in early January of 2017,
they clapper and call me and Brendan leaked this dossier to the
press, which had already been circulated out there,
but giving it their stamp of, we know it exists, and we're going to brief this,
right? So we,
they briefed it to president elect Trump and the very act of doing that and
saying, Hey,
you should be aware that this exists suddenly gave the hook for the press to run
with this story, that we have a Russian agent sitting in the white house,
the FBI and the CIA, you know, they believed enough in his document to brief it.
And then of course the fire was set, right?
The brush fire took off the hysteria was launched,
but what's amazing is the next number of days in the next couple of weeks,
every one of those bastards, comi and clapper, Brandon, all of them said, Oh,
but you know the dossier, we don't believe it. I guess it's just,
it's just rumors. Well then why'd your briefing?
Why did you spread it around Washington?
Because you knew that it would cause a brush fire.
You knew it would set this nation on fire.
And you knew that the Trump presidency would likely, never recover from it.
And in fact,
John Brennan told a crowd here in Los Angeles that president Trump would no
longer be an office interview. He gave in at, by the end of 2018,
he told a bunch of these Hollywood elites. Don't worry about it.
Trump's going to be gone by the end of 2018.
Thank God John Brennan was gone and now he's under criminal investigation.
Okay. So that was my next question. How,
how nervous should clapper and Brennan and Comey be? I mean,
clapper is the guy who lied under oath when they asked him about, uh,
are we doing master balance on people are in our own citizens and what it was it
not wittingly that he said as he was scratching the top of his head,
which you ever see that episode of Seinfeld, you know,
when you're lying the higher up on your face that you scratch,
it tells you if it's a big lie or not. I mean, he's literally going, not winning
starts crying, but then, but then,
but then becomes like a CNN analyst on this and suffers ramifications for lying
under oath, right? How, how much trouble do you think these guys really,
I think they're on.
And I think that they know it and I am as a, as an American,
forget my party affiliation, forget it. You know, having worked in the CIA,
although that's a part of my anger,
because I know what they've done to the intelligence community they have now
made the American people reasonably concerned about a degree of politicization
that they were aware of or that they thought would be impossible.
So they have really solely not only the reputation,
but the ability of the FBI and the CIA to go out and do the good work that they
need to do. We do in fact, need an FBI and CIA to do the good work that they do,
but it's reasonable for an American to step back and say,
maybe we shouldn't have these guys because they're highly politicized.
So I think that Brennan and, and collaborate,
and that whole cabal that was involved in these shenanigans in 2016 should be
very worried. John Durham, a very, very smart man.
And I think AGU bars playing a long game on this one,
I think he's letting comi go on some of the smaller stuff. I mean,
he's hitting them hard in some areas.
And the IgE has called him a dangerous man, a man who,
a dangerous precedent for the 30 plus thousand former and current FBI employees.
And I think you're going to find the same thing, uh, with, with, with, uh,
clapper and Brennan.
So if these guys did so much bad stuff,
what do you make of the fact that they don't shut up? Like,
what do you make of the fact that Comey wrote the book? You know,
which nobody bought the books, they pushing the hell out and teaches ethics.
What is happening in this world? Or look at Brennan's Twitter feed.
It's just like, wait a minute. You were the head of the CIA.
I don't think you should be like,
you're basically attacking one of the institutions,
the office of the presidency. Now I get it. Trump attacks everybody too.
So there's nobody that's totally clean here. But like, I, you know,
you look at Brennan's Twitter feed and it's like, what, what are you doing?
What, but they don't,
I guess they feel that they'll never be caught if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about politics instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.